[Applause]
oh and it was nicki minaj's moment as
she brought all her fans the barbs along
for her vma performance
and received the 2022 video vanguard
award it's one of the best feelings in
the world the rapper returned to the vma
stage for the first time in four years
taking fans down memory lane
and performing some of her biggest hits
including super base
battles and he got the right kind of he
called his health he myself he always
[Applause]
yeah check out taylor swift wrapping the
lyrics flawlessly
i mean it's pretty obvious
nicki also performs her newest banker
super freaky girl
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a big night for minaj as she's this
year's winner of the michael jackson
video vanguard award
and there's no one better to introduce
her than the barbs themselves
we are here on behalf of all the barbs
all over the planet this is such an
incredible honor to be on the stage
tonight and to be part of this huge
moment for the reigning queen of hip hop
congratulations to the 2022 mtv video
vanguard
nicki minaj
in her acceptance speech nikki thanks
the celebs who inspired her the most
lil wayne foxy brown lauren hill
jay-z slick rick dougie fresh
[Applause]
and then i wrote people who
gave me huge opportunities that i'll
never forget
kanye west beyonce
madonna mariah carey eminem britney
spears rihanna
and while remembering the grades she
gives a message about mental health i
wish that whitney houston
and michael jackson were here
i wish that people understood what they
meant and what they were going through i
wish people took mental health seriously
even for the people who you think have
the perfect lives but nikki couldn't
leave the stage without shouting out her
two-year-old son
you know what thank you thank you so
much
um and two you guys are my babies but i
have a new baby i have a new baby his
name is papa bear and i love you happy i
love you so much
mommy loves you so so so so so much but
you guys thank you
[Music]
you